let's go to our caller from the 404
who's calling today from 4:04 hey David
it's Dustin from Atlanta hey just uh
just hey I just wanted your take on this
so the whole never Biden crew I do get
their sentiments but I don't I can't for
the life of me and I know you feel
similar to this understand the logic
behind that and I was just wondering if
you could you know further explain your
thoughts because I don't want to feel
like I'm the weird one for not voting or
for voting for Biden if it comes down to
that you know so what you want to hear
from me why I think it makes sense to
vote Biden or what I think is motivating
than ever Biden people um just a little
bit about this your your take on okay so
the never Biden people fall into a few
different categories
you've got never Biden people who are of
the mindset that if it's not someone as
left as Bernie they might as well let it
be another four years of Trump so
there's folks that are sort of not
really making much of a distinction
between Biden and Trump saying if it's
either of them it's basically the same
thing I don't care I'm opting out
whatever so that's that's one group
you've got another group that says I
would conceivably vote for Biden but I
can't allow my vote to be a blank check
for the Democratic Party so just because
Bernie lost doesn't mean I automatically
go to buy Biden needs to do do something
either needs to adopt some Bernie policy
or reach out to me in some way or
something like that because they don't
want the the DNC to assume their vote
without having to actually work for it
is sort of another group then you've
also got you know kind of more
anarchistic types of the burn it all
down to build it back up mentality I
don't think that's a predominant amount
I also don't think that that's a
strategy that has really served us well
in the past so for me my approach is the
following this is not about vote blue no
matter who and in fact if we weren't
talking about Biden or Bernie versus
Trump
we were talking about someone terrible I
wouldn't vote for that person if the
person was worse than Trump I wouldn't
vote or I would vote for Trump we're
dealing and we've been dealing for a
while all with candidates who would be
better than Trump so for me it's not
about did Biden earn my vote or whatever
it's the choices are
unless something completely insane
happens because of coronavirus the
choices are Biden or Trump and Biden is
clearly better Biden's better on Supreme
Court justices Biden's better on taxes
Biden's better on climate Biden's right
so is Biden the most progressive guy of
course not but you're giving me a choice
and there's no way that I can morally
justify taking any action that makes it
more likely Trump will be reelected
that's my view okay yeah cuz I see I'm
in a lot of Facebook groups you know the
the Twitter stuff about Bernie and the
Facebook groups there's there's a large
there's a large group of people that
feel feel the same way as the never
Biden people I mean it's it's it's
really it's got an extreme the way I've
seen it kinda yeah manifest the the only
thing I disagree with you the one thing
I would say is in the same way that
Twitter and reddit overstated how much
support Bernie was going to have in the
primary when that support we saw topped
out the never Biden stuff is also
over-represented now the thing is you
don't need that much of it to help Trump
because a lot of these states are going
to be very close so a little bit of
never Biden stuff from the left in
Michigan could give Michigan to Trump I
don't want to pretend that it doesn't
matter I just think it's important not
to believe that there's way more of that
stuff than there actually is but there
may well be enough to give the election
to Trump okay well thank you for taking
my question David thank you for calling
in I appreciate hearing from you